speaking of absurdities there is a
segment of the American population that
is absolutely okay with Russian
involvement in our campaigns there's a
study that came out from the Yahoo
Finance SurveyMonkey poll and I want to
pull that quote up on your screen so I
can just give it to you in their own
words a Yahoo Finance SurveyMonkey poll
released Tuesday finds that 11% of
Republicans or GOP leaning Americans
surveyed said that it is appropriate
that's right appropriate for Russia to
try to help Republicans while 29% said
that it's not appropriate but it
wouldn't be a big deal so about 40% 40%
of Republicans have no problem
whatsoever it might be it might be
significant but it's not a big deal it
might be an issue or not appropriate but
it's not a big deal
40% of Republicans are okay with
Russians involving themselves in our
elections now and when I say Russians
involving themselves in our elections I
don't mean this overly simplified
communist Red Scare that's going on in
some were put in democratic circles I'm
talking about Republica Russians
literally involving themselves and
possibly turning the results of an
election in favor of someone who is a
fascist leaning aspiring dictator and
you have Republicans who say yeah it's
no big deal no big deal as shocking is
that is this next slide this next quote
is a little more shocking to me pull it
up on the screen it says this on the
Democratic side fourteen percent of
Democrats said it would either be
appropriate or wouldn't be a big deal
for Russia to intervene 86 percent
called it not appropriate and a major
and major for Russians to try to help
Democrats now mind you maybe six percent
is a huge overwhelming majority but I'm
sorry who the hell are these 14 percent
of Democrats who say that it's no big
deal or appropriate for Russia to
involve themselves in our elections this
is this makes no sense to me I really
want to know who these Democrats are
like where where do you not only where
do you live but but who are you what do
you what do you actually stand for what
do you even care about it
you don't care about a foreign nation
flipping our elections possibly flipping
our elections what do you even care
about I mean I don't I'm trying to be
sure these people actually exist maybe
that's a statistical error I I don't
know but the point is is that somewhere
in this country and particularly in the
conservative circles there's a large
group of people who see absolutely
nothing wrong with Russia and here's
here's the reality underneath it the
reality underneath it is that they don't
care because it gave them Donald Trump
potentially the investigation is still
ongoing you can make that call for
yourself but they don't care because it
worked out in their favor and that shows
you the extent of the hyper partisanship
that exists in this country that that
they have no qualms whatsoever with a
foreign government potentially involving
themselves in our election process so
much so that they could have given us
Donald Trump they don't care so long as
their side won that shows you that their
allegiance is not to the United States
of America all all of these all these
overtures of patriotism all these
overtures of you better stand for the
flag NFL players all of their concerns
about you know the red white and blue
and respecting our country and
respecting our veterans but when it
comes down to it they are more concerned
with their party than any sense of
nationalism any sense of of a patriotism
they are more committed to their
political party in other words let me
flip the statement in other words
they're willing to betray this country
in order to maintain political power so
when it comes down to this whole
question of who loves America more which
is a ridiculous question in the first
place
but let's operate within that premise
let's operate within that framework who
loves the country more people who have
no concern about a foreign government
involving themselves in our election or
people who take a knee during the pledge
in order to protest system McVeigh lence
against black people in this country who
loves this country more I don't even
have to finish the question because you
already know the answer today's program
brought to you in part by Blink accom
slash Pakman blinka
is a great service that I use all the
time what they do is they take thousands
of the most popular non-fiction books
including the newest bestsellers they
condense them into 15-minute audiobooks
that you can listen to and you still get
the most crucial information and
insights from each book and I've
listened to a ton of books on blink Asst
I recently checked out
soccer na mcc's by Simon Cooper we do
have after all the World Cup going on
recently we also have been talking about
BS jobs and there is a great new book BS
jobs by David Graeber which I listened
to on bling cos they're constantly
adding new books to the platform you
will never run out of fascinating and
critically acclaimed books to enjoy and
our audience can get a 7 day free trial
by going to blink Escom slash Pakman if
you're watching on YouTube I'm putting a
link in the video description and after
the free trial if you like it you can
continue enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about 5 bucks a month
that's be Li NK is t.com /pa que mas